monday Monday Labor Day Labor Day ladies
and gentlemen I'm back from Utah fresh
as a daisy
oh man you talk love you talk yeah
warming more and more just bones
everywhere a huge Kong and Simone's yes
apparently they have a they have a
program where you get automatic
citizenship if you join the Mormon I
heard cuz I couldn't
white whites but but I was like there
are some giant Tongan and Samoans and no
in between right
no in between and apparently when you
are when your son or daughter especially
your son is playing on a playground with
all a little Tongan and the Samoan kids
your son is basically a pool ball
because they roughhouse they play some
roughhouse they take over the [ __ ]
play glacier do not a not my tee tees
they're my titi he's been watching a lot
of Moana he will slap the [ __ ] out of my
wife
he can hang with his mounts you know
what titi lights he's the bully a
Playgirl is that right and I try to not
celebrate inside well have to tell be a
good parent tell me I've literally
watched Moana
six times in three days pray yeah my
kids are are a little too thin they're
thin they've got their it's not a dad's
bounce truck no it's not roughhousing
not with my son
little too little too uh that's a long
and thin but now he ain't gonna be lean
but like the tiger hope not believe
those kids with like there's this like
rubber wheel and he'll get on it like
the hamster wheel and just truck all the
kids I'm like yeah quit doing that
although it's hilarious because the kids
try and push back we just truck them
over and he's younger than although yeah
so then he like dominates what whatever
that and we get home like I think you're
badass huh like around have you had him
checked as he endure like ninety to
ninety nine percent
he's ninety nine yeah for everything so
he's a giant well they said they said he
would they know for sure he won't be
under six - he'll be six - or taller
than Wow yeah because the the when I see
the Tong and Samoans in Utah I always
think to myself thank God we don't live
in a time where might makes right and
where you can just shove your well no
not enough cuz we gang up you getting uh
I get my get my small whites together
and be like guys guys sorry there's
100,000 there's 50 of you giants that's
we're gonna jump you we have to swarm
you're right white privilege and jump
yeah
this boot made by Doc Martin like a
bunch of hyenas on our line of pineapple
stomp
we pineapple stomping you ha how annoyed
were you and I pulled up today oh my god
dude he's got that swing about that
Deathmobile
it's a think of a motor saying it's a
three wheeler and it's got how much
horse have powers is that it's nothing
move oh yeah super it's got a belt so
got it like a like a bicycle commotion I
back yeah it's fast to get on the 405
today not saying I just put my hair in
the wind man get my ray-bans on I feel
like you get dizzy all this smog no like
Paul Newman I feel like a badass but
then I was on PCH going about a hundred
just messing around that night yeah oh
my god if someone just pulls out it done
oh it's it's game day yeah there's no
there's nothing but it's fun I'm sick I
don't know
like I said they I didn't buy it they
sent it to me this can be sent to me
what's the company pourer sent it to me
but that's the Freak my but anyways they
sent to me I got for like a month or two
just to mess around with it it's been
fun
you know drumstick man yeah I don't know
it's cool it's not freaking Batmobile
it's about mobile I would drive the
speed limit it would be lost on me and
I'd probably be driving around my
neighborhood with a helmet on it's
almost a thing you need a helmet out for
well you you're supposed to have a helm
on yo yeah yellow chill mmm you rabble
me rebel don't say mmm no Matt he pulls
up you see that man scram he's like a
Janet Jackson for you
Malik at Bruce Wayne I do feel like a
super low budget Bruce Wayne in that
thing that's a guy thing my mother when
she said if you ever buy a motorcycle
I'm going to run it over I will run it
over with my car if you ever show up
with a motorcycle because my mother I
love my mother very intelligent woman
but if my mother only looks for danger
my mother only can see it's that joke I
do where I'd walk out with a scarf and
I'm not kidding she got don't wear a
scarf and I was like it's freezing
I know but escalators it it gets caught
your head well yeah that's like
literally yeah did you eat make sure you
eat if you don't eat you're faint you
know I mean she's like a risk analyzer
Oh Mike she's like Along Came Polly
well kidnappers fast moving cars ledges
and of course I used to torture and
poison she's to warn me about poison you
think I'm thinking getting poison and
tetanus weird [ __ ] like have you got a
cut you didn't clean it out you can get
tetanus and old nails so I'll keep
talking about yeah yeah I'm not playing
around with rusty nails even now even
now fifty like we go to Utah it's were
sort of yeah it's worse than now getting
worse as they get older it she'll say
things like don't eat now because you'll
ruin your appetite
oh oh oh my god I'm fifty so she's gotta
change some habits my dad hides from her
you just need to break Papa hide Papa
hug my father at seventy seven years old
has improved his golf game takes three
hours of Italian don't ask me why
practice is the keytar he's retired
yeah the guitar and then has a reading
list a mile long but I give you he just
keeps done if you wanna do you die yeah
like Pete you know set people that
retire and they have no like passion or
something to follow yep they die that's
what he said
he said to me he goes no you you you'll
get I'll die how about this how about
this I decide my brain and my words
didn't I hear that happens me sometimes
uh we went shooting my dad shooting he's
got himself a little thousand dollar
Brennan in the Labor Day
you don't say loads obvious Labor Day
don't my dad went even further your
follows man it's my father bro don't see
that well I was oh you weren't doing I
mean in that sexual type man you go load
so make me get razor Brown out oh my god
alright I shot a couple guns I'm gonna
go through it shotguns now my dad's got
a three thousand dollar handmade 1911
that's a 45 trigger fingers made in 1911
well it's the same design as 1911 it's a
handmade gun do you you spend a minimum
3 grand on that gun ok keeps it in a
case
keeps in a little bag he brings it with
him we go to the shootings I got to rent
my guns
I got myself a Springfield don't worry
what that is then I shot myself an
assault rifle on a cave no I'm sorry an
ar-15 no not automatic but it was a
semi-automatic ar-15s assault right yeah
well you can put it on burst well don't
do that don't don't do that but whose
it's it was out you can put it on first
if it's if it's military issue this is
an issue see I only shoot military but I
can you know what they call me when I
shoot do you know what they call me and
this is for all cockeyed down they go
like this they go when I should they go
it broke hey got guy nope no targets
over here it's full hey Doc got gallon I
shoot over here she were both eyes open
and then the head guy goes nice the big
divers do whatever you want bro I shoot
with both eyes open I'm left-eye
dominant you even know what that means
now yeah hold on hold on for a sec so
you shoot like this they go when you see
me shell shoot like this yeah of course
you do because your amateur when they
see me shoot they go like this they go
dude what's it like at the bottom of the
ocean I go wow they go dude what's it
like to eat fish in one cup I'm like
what are you talking about and they go
we're obviously a grouper I go what do
you mean they go we group you could you
shoot tight groups you mind if we call
you the the grouper a grouper I feel
like there's been a name for that I
wouldn't want a different angle from my
group because you made it I grew up
group Maddon when I said that to my dad
driving away I haven't seen him in Hoyt
in my 50 years I've never seen him more
normally he was like what did you say I
go call me the group but from now on I
group them up he goes yeah 25 feet oh
yeah what are you talking about grouper
they thought you're the American sniper
yeah yeah dude do you enjoy shooting
those done guns
I don't can I tell you out is for me I
go let's I went to the range scary guy
also that's not till arrangement with
the kid with a mental disability should
not have ak-47s anyway and had a seizure
yeah everyone's freaked out yes true
story yeah anyways ah you know it gave
me Desert Eagle first gun Oh
big dude ok great we're so yeah you know
it's crazy what else you got that's cool
did you cocoon what else you got -
alright how long we here at least
another hour yeah I don't see you like
here's what I feel with guns I because
they're so violent and as they scare me
they make me a little depressed I do my
back seizes up I said oh how about young
with it yeah I like shooting I like the
I like sort of the it's really sort of
if you practice the marksmanship of edit
the technique there's a lot of technique
to I'm sure but I I or a guy like me
that doesn't go that much yeah I grew up
do hunt but not I don't shoot real ducks
like if you have like these cool like
clay ducks I'm down to like make a game
out of it you don't yeah you're not a
guy who likes violence no you just don't
shower you're not yeah and I was
actually in a lot of ways I'm the same
way like when I see it and I feel the
force of that bullet like I was shooting
that assault rifle at ar-15 and man that
that goes three Tyler bullets three
times faster than a pistol so when I
when you get hit with an ar-15 anywhere
you're a real tree it's just that's all
that fun it's like create it's not yeah
I don't know well it's a weapon of war
so so it's it's it guns like that are
made to kill things and I think that
that's a place you don't usually want to
be you know you know it reminds you of
how real [ __ ] can get yeah that's fair
enough
that's fair yeah but I think I do it
because because of that it kind of keeps
me a little bit I like to feel a little
uncomfortable sometimes I don't know I
honestly like little comfortable you and
your dad hunting each other well they
here's the other problem with like
shooting good arguing you got a mining
rant I'm uncomfortable I just yeah like
after the initial thriller find that gun
yeah it's loud yes
you know what that happens a lot in
shooting ranges you know suicides so
people will rent a gun yes and go and
shoot and just shoot themselves there's
a lot of that really and and sometimes
people go and kill other people in yeah
I was know what a terrible place to try
and commit murder everyone else has a
gun and you're not gonna kill that man
yeah it's but you know there's a lot of
suicide there but yes you not a weird
stuff that goes on with was that we're
[ __ ] homeboy from American sniper
died by a guy teaching this exactly
right out of shooting that he had PTSD
really bad ah do American hair you son
of a [ __ ] yeah well he was he was he
was really trying to deal and Chris Kyle
was trying to help him you know he had a
program with shooting and I guess the
guy just freaked out
oh man yeah and stuff go positive note
here
college football started you [ __ ] by
the way I don't know college football
but I was watching men a little older
than me freak out over Alabama I think I
beat the [ __ ] I FSU that was a great
game all those crunk for it the big game
was last night UCLA for 6 a.m. think
UCLA was down 35 and you know I love
football Nona's my house left football
so when they went up like by 20 hours I
got [ __ ] it and just changes they're
watching Game of Thrones got my Campari
and soda
why are people so insane about college
football I feel like they're even
crazier about college football than they
are about pro football am i right amount
matter am I wrong I think it depends
like college football there's like a
sense of pride like especially because
it represent you know I'm saying you
went ahead I went there yeah I think a
lot of Peters like a lot of alumni like
if you're a fan of the Broncos they
represent Denver but you have no like
title it's a business it's more of a
business I don't care as much about
university you actually was more part of
that universe I think that's why there's
such strong tie yeah it's crazy like
when Michigan State plays Michigan you
know like two different USC SC and then
right now cultural one la is really good
cuz UCLA has a ridiculous quarterback
than USC has a ridiculous quarterback so
it's good yeah and Stanford's good yeah
it's cool different I was just Lauren
land I'll call me who trains like
everybody yeah man he's straight Neil
Magny firs upcoming fighting all the
other guys and he trains Christian
McCaffrey there's like great white hope
it had dropped in the first round of
Carolina and from what I hear there
people are saying like this kids the
next like great thing as a light running
back is really because dad was AB legend
to read McCaffrey favorite player grown
up
well he was here running back as well
receiver ok went to Stanford to stud
super stud and so his sons just his
freak so Lauren flies to Carolina cos in
camp right now they're just ending camp
isn't seen it starts next week and
Lauren flies there once a week to work
on them just to like I I always say this
about and I'm really not being dramatic
I swear to God the exercises lauren
landau gave me cured my lower back him
and my balloon
flowers yeah I swear to God yeah change
my [ __ ] I'm serious when I say that he
changed my his adult life
he's wrote one book in one session he
got literally goes around the world
doing seminars yeah
any Peyton Manning he works with Peyton
man like the biggest world yeah he's got
a great book out and I can't remember I
read it it was good strengthen condition
for mixed martial arts right Lauren
cover
block is my royalty hey Lauren hey
Lauren I sold seven of them but I still
want my money yeah let's just let's get
some lunch let's get some more salt no
he knows his [ __ ] man
he really does yeah I'm excited for
football super excited we guess supposed
to guest in the house today Brian MJ MJ
I knew that Mike MJ and Chinon and
Brennan were were very involved in the
selection process it was kind of like it
was the kind of selection process that
Navy SEALs go through and you made it
through very strict they read they
really liked you
so and now I like it uh it's a skill
hiring people it's a straight-up skill
what was it about what was it about MJ
that you uh letting her talk yet yeah
yeah right and welcome to find key you
don't interrupt everyone don't listen so
welcome this show um just that you can
tell she's good person but she also has
her ear to the ground so our social
media she's super smart double major her
background too I don't think she's gonna
[ __ ] this up you know and you're from
here Santa Rita so it's a little a
little more north what does MJ stand for
Megan Jane
damn right it does Megan Jane and she
also has some color tortas like her
backgrounds pretty crazy you know like
we like boring people mm-hmm their
backgrounds pretty great but we were
talking about that a lot of times people
who haven't had much go on in their
background they respond in two ways from
my experience this is just from my
experience but if you've had no trauma
if you had no hardship typically what
will happen is you will either become
sort of a happy-go-lucky boring person
or you will be very neurotic and very
worried that's
thing is going to happen because you've
never experienced it so when you've
never experienced law so you don't know
how to navigate it you're waiting for it
to happen because you don't have the
tools you don't know you don't know how
you would react right so Phil Bryan in
the listener defined kid listener and
she talked about a little bit on the big
ground breakdown just your background
how you got here cuz you're talking a
different crowd I'm still very blessed
I've been through some things but I'm
really really grateful for what I have
right now alright now I'm going to
school I'm double-majoring business and
marketing and King see ology I teach
yoga I gotta know I'm like nervous even
like on there sorry it's not right oh my
god always forget that some people are
not used to talking on a mic yeah yeah
and I've been pretty independent since
an early age didn't have the best
upbringing it was pretty dark and now
I'm out of that and I'm self-sufficient
and now I just want to help those around
me and keep growing so I'm just really
ambitious and focused right now on
getting them up on my degrees and
getting through with my career and I
think this would be the best way to keep
going with them a huge fan of you guys
she's like Doogie Howser start going to
school and she's like 14 yeah I did my
first year college um this summer after
I finished eighth grade she's yeah and I
started so that summer and then did the
college dance company walls at my high
school so you were a dancer Wow yeah I
used to do you like prima ballerina -
they're cool a little bit of everything
just like POI dancing and fun stuff yeah
I like to try everything oh yeah I've
been known to cut a rug myself I could
lie right now but I won't so I should
probably tell you I can cut a rug myself
Ryan why is your skin so tight probably
dance probably the fact that I dance
private dancer I'm a dancer would you do
this Abby did you do anything this
weekend it's not too crazy yeah just
honestly just some homework kind of lame
stuff and I'm supposed to go to Lake but
there's a bunch of fires in my town
there it's actually the biggest fire in
LA history yeah so you started by
dancing Gill will show you some spice
well if you did start it don't worry
about it because I could show up start
dancing cuz my hips are like water come
on give me some I'm at huh
well I'm glad your weekend was full of
fire but I want to know how genders
weekend what Shin listen before you
start yeah and we blast out on the farm
kid social media so it's official you
had friends over and you're swiping left
and right with girls yeah I have so many
people DMing me like hey man I'm on
tinder it's the easiest thing ever then
went chin is way too [ __ ] picky just
dumb to swipe on everything right hell
no bro you saw some of the pictures all
right I did see something up all right
little sambal there's no water for him
he's in a little deep water take it
easily he's still got his water wings on
I know we can't take his water wings off
right away I'm trying to take his water
wings one off in Otago but if Jacque
Cousteau goes hey I've tried this
underwater I'm gonna [ __ ] listen you
know I understand that but you wait
comes a date I feel like you and I are
no your life's not a couple Jacques
Cousteau's but here's the thing
we're a couple dig divers a couple dick
divers now here's the thing yeah you're
not he still hasn't even gotten his face
in the water yet he doesn't know how to
breathe yet the thing is this is this is
my issue with chin and this whole dating
thing car yeah you got all the gear get
those cool goggles on you're rather
sweet mouth we've spent a lot of money
on get what is that a seed sea-dweller
Rolex got shark cage around you so
nothing Bad's gonna happen to you two
experts up now we're right here
you got a shark a there plus we got a
spear gun all right water I swipe so
take it easy don't be so please let me
coax him hold on hey yeah hey let's put
her toe in the water for sale in there
okay don't be talkin over there don't be
talking just take that big old corinto
go yeah come over here come over into me
don't push him
don't push on it don't push him relax
Jen come over no my left
she knew what I would do you know I do
Jim I would cannonball on that goddamn
what Brennan not yet
goddammit stop being so forceful let me
wait he's emotional right now what have
you done what did you do this weekend
you post a picture and you you put the
tinder profiles on my giant TV my
friends wanted the especially the girls
water to pick girls it's the best game
ever
I didn't show it to me I was like oh my
god I could do this all night what is
that what is that like they a picture
profile and you just like left if you
like or right oh no you swipe no I don't
like them right if you like them so I'd
go through it jongshin's profile yes Jim
yes no no yes no more wear nose though
right there's some salt yes as though
what you did say yes to that's I feel
like you're so picky chin that you're
making it very difficult in do you think
that maybe the ones that you're swiping
no you know it's just a question just
say it do you think that you would swipe
more left if and if if this is maybe
maybe this is our way of kind of going
hey maybe you're gonna burst you're
gonna maybe you're gonna bust and a
couple episodes ago I'm gay you're not
hating or maybe you're like if I'm like
hey how's tinder companies like not good
am i quiet what's wrong with Timmy like
if you do like Grindr we will never ever
judge you the chance not yeah oh yeah
it's not gay I know he's not I know it's
not what I mean the ones I don't know
people are telling me a lot of people
are writing and saying like swipe right
on everything like hundreds agree that
with that and then and then start
talking they're just a bunch of
different ones just talk game up even
though girls are with me they're more
pickier than I am
for me they would pick like if they say
someone's a super super hot
they automatically go you know
high-maintenance oh those are haters no
no [ __ ] the hoes you can't have that you
don't want girls helping you out
you're like tap hose go ahead guys Jose
not hose that's the life you live man
you can't have that [ __ ] you need to
have your boys to side cuz I'm trying to
each other
sloppy slop Hey
let's get married loyal to you what what
are you nervous about are you nervous no
no I'm doing it I'm just not getting
matched up no one's fast enough with you
have a zero matches how many swipe
rights have you done you think how a
grand total of maybe like with yet with
the stuff our friends did maybe like 30
okay world it's a lie
we're over 30 that's not okay you want I
like a challenge we got a work cut out
for us maybe that's ok I'll try a big
favor and you're welcome in advance
shoot a fish no capital put Brian put my
face up the plastic and face it there or
or yours no not mine should we slip a
bond account dick pic special 12 these
hoes I got a piece now you got to be
ready cuz they're gonna be like what the
bomb well no but then at least he's
there you know we'll take it from there
when I first met Brent and I am I sent
his I'm sent him a couple dick pics I
just went I hope you guys are having a
good day you and Tony Jeffries are yeah
that's right
and em Jake he's sending Brian who's
this that's my profile picture and then
they could say that's the profile and
I'm gonna suit everyone says a suit and
with people and then if you keep swiping
enjoy it like it's curious and then you
go to the other pictures and then I
there's one I'm holding a dog I like the
dog yeah I like to talk the dog one I
look chin you're a good-looking guy
thank you you are the guys look like a
Korean gangster who you don't you also
look like you're seven feet tall
towering over all the other people in
the picture and then it says Korea's
tallest man you gotta see so funny
no I like that yeah you just don't wanna
make sure they were my should they're
like is he a pituitary case oh hello
[ __ ] big yeah once yeah yeah he's
like I'm a giant Choi
what what is it there are certain
pictures that I just and here's a touch
of the down hey they're pulling they're
pulling focus is what I'm what Brennan's
fancy you just looked at Grant in
Brandon knows if the type of human that
is there's an issue look Brandon can
help you with how to frame yourself
every picture you you frame yourself
with tiny Asian people around you like
you're a king that's like your game a
throne right like I'm the king of all
the Asians I'm a giant giant and
sometimes I can be intimidating
that's why I have to make fun of it
because I'm so much taller than long
well geez once eat peanuts off their
head while you're out you know what I'm
saying like I mean why don't you put a
tray on their head and eat food see I
feel like you're good telling so much
bigger than everybody else are you in
this with an Oscar that guy on the far
right here just touch of the downs not
that it matters I feel so bad for this
guy do you know I'm talking about
does he have does he had his head there
down so he does it he's just joking
around in the picture it makes me kind
of look like he is I feel so bad for
right now why by the way I like it
you're trying to be really delicate a
touch of the bounce is full blown down
but he does it which is awesome I'll
show you pictures of a lot not making
faces I mean if I was him I would be yes
I'm like bro all the pictures yeah I'm
trying to get my dick wet - you got me
looking like [ __ ] simple jack on your
profile is simple jack I see man I think
we need more pictures of just you on
their chin you're over 30 put like like
four or five yeah so let's take the
[ __ ] class pics down there tilt Oh
like if you have people telling you to
put different pictures on they want you
to do group pictures to see but I don't
see your headline your leadoff is a
group picture it's like I which one am I
trying to [ __ ] with here
I don't know all right I'll just
confusing so people still are too much
swipe left yeah sure it's possible all
right so what the puffy hood our differ
were yeah because you know what
sometimes when you're when you're with a
group of people it might signal that
you're not so confident whereas you want
to be standing alone so maybe stand all
superhero shorts with your
with your fists on your side on a rock
on a rock going more to tight white
pants get half a boner and just push it
down cr1 the way Conor McGregor does
yeah that guy wear some tight pants he's
got a piece on yeah I guess then MJ do
you tinder any of that stuff do you mess
any those dating sites no I've never
been on a dating website you have any
advice for a chin with this is from a
female point of view I definitely agree
with Brian that you should put the first
photo as you because throws more
confidence really is it shows way more
confidence because otherwise people are
channeling look through and they think
that you're just gonna hide behind other
people let's go sure and I think the dog
one should be the second one because the
you put the dog one is recruiting it's a
little too much like you're trying yeah
but like girls love dogs [ __ ] love
[ __ ] so koala one's like a that's
like the winner I think that one you
should do is that you last one I got our
pictures all right those goddamn notes
down to my 4:30 here come to my town
we'll take some photos of you all right
we're going Vasquez rocks what so let's
say you nab the fish on the old Korean
fish hook line there you are got any
suggestions as far as first dates go um
what shouldn't he do let's start there
from a girl's point of view don't worry
about spending a lot of money don't at
all and then don't do anything creepy
like let's meet at this really obscure
hike hiking school make me feel like the
second or third day I know you like
hiking but I would never say I knew you
unless I knew you keeps going
okay so come on come on come into the
woods with me I get in this random
bullet and [ __ ] let's hike for seven
days why can't why wait your spring you
did toilet paper you will have to take a
pillow tell your friends where you're
going it's more fun that way leave your
cell phone behind it doesn't work
anyways alright movies are kind of
awkward unless you do horror movies like
I personally love scary horror movies
girl because because you don't know like
brought like a physical contact and then
it's a good way to see if the girl you
know if she jumps and scared then you
can just like get that for
is contact you know like that you're
like I got you girl grab it to it you
know and then the girl can see if you're
a wisp us or not she's like all got this
guy's like [ __ ] like he's totally
dumping more than I yeah girl that's a
good point yeah scary purse just go just
start laughing go not on my watch am i
right how you doing good
you all know that you want know the role
oh yeah a light touch okay I grabbed her
heart [ __ ] stoke a [ __ ] you want you
want squirt of the hitch my eye oh hey
you're a crash shut up it muskan no but
you know what they say about scary
movies that scary movies in the human
body especially with women it gives off
it releases the same dorphman endorphins
as sexual sexual tension so yeah like
when they get scared you know I'm saying
chin so that she's a great point with
the scary movies she'd be ready to go so
they did an experiment well four is like
being attracted to I'm not saying she
was sacred dick in your city but they
didn't experiment with women where they
put the same guy in front of it like a
really precarious bridge and they're
gonna have to cross this really scary
rope bridge and and then they had him
found like a regular like you know like
I'm Bridget you could walk through and
the when when the women they were asked
to rate him like his attractiveness they
all said the women who had to cross the
scary bridge when they were put in a
state of fear they said oh that guy was
attractive they were they were their
sexuality was heightened because
sexuality it's science for died safely
damn accountants you know nothing Jon
Snow um what else you guys mom and I
don't like sports but I mean I think
active things like paintballing just to
get like running around and get out get
out of the house like nothing dominate
that [ __ ] there's sports up or like if
you wanna do a movie thing they showed
jaws on the beach like last week
somewhere in huntin Beach I think that's
cool because he can bring stuff also the
cemetery there movies at the cemetery
especially Halloween coming up blanket
is that it goes anyways but you can do
that but also with movies
stuff because you're in earth evening
can't talk about two hours you don't get
to know each other you can talk after
though kind of but outside is gonna be
better honestly I always had so much
success just at a good meal with really
good wine really look at me right now
yeah you [ __ ] at 50 yeah you look at
me yeah baby hey we can speed up with
white wine red wine in red money
you know you doing well right yeah
that's uh that's like me going you know
what chin I tell it it was easy for me I
just gotta you have seen him punch girls
in the face alright hold on chin if
we're on a date we're having dinner just
like can I get some wine maybe later Oh
see I don't think I'm fancy awkward
dinners away to God okay I think that's
so old-school be it mate it's fortunate
to be someone you're not so and let the
girl it's awkward for them fifty let's
take a hike on the dating advice all
right there's a lot of fun things to do
around town you can always find like
cool bookstores oh yeah you know they
could see what she like I don't know
there's always like you can find super
slump-buster not [ __ ] roller coasters
if that was like thing you do here Six
Flags Magic I mean that's for a first
date take her that's matter like Hello
oh you know you could do surf lessons
oh god oh let's all get naked well that
way you can see how she really looks cuz
her makeup will come off - oh no but but
surf lessons in a bad idea
you get an old wet suit looking a wets I
like - scary movie the most so far
dave & buster's that's a fun time cuz
you can get drinks and snacks there and
then turn plates and arms second place
dave and buster's in a bad idea there's
Buffalo Wild Wings next up movie
theaters upstairs over let me write up
here I think I horror movies good yeah I
like the movie but listen Halloween's
coming up so the cemetery every week has
a movie done you go the cemetery I don't
dress up like now does that make him
sound like he's a ghoulish no not at all
no it's like the cool thing dressed like
the [ __ ] now
don't dress up druid don't dress up like
a character from [ __ ] wear a hood
Lawrence don't do that unless you want
hello hello
thou shalt not pass Jenny's wait I'm
taking you to the underground
I'm career I'm I'm [ __ ] alert romantic
family I'm lurch from the Evans family
she's all you know what this is it let's
do cocaine and see a movie
match ever happens I feel like you've
been the horse help
MJ's been good I've been awful too but
you're old for 30 yeah so I gotta get a
match first before we can even start
talking about the next Oh 4:30 there is
it you could take her to a shooting
range
oh shoot that's that's a little freaky I
think nobody you can say I never I've
never shot guns what makes a girl feel
pretty badass she's if she liked you
would meet someone brand new and go to a
gun range I sure wouldn't it's a
terrible idea that's it so Brian want
you to go hiking alone with her shooting
guns fancy restaurant and wine [ __ ]
hell Street what about a live event oh
my god what about a live event what
about like a play or something like that
Hollywood wall yeah like a live event
like where your cuz then you can talk
and then you're like around a lot of
people that might be interesting right
there's something not too long something
kind of sure you're the concert though
it's just or the bride counts comedy you
know that would be honest you're busted
I will give you the red carpet many are
performing at The Comedy Store I'm not
idea you bring you [ __ ] bring her to
our show we'll get you great seats and
put we'll put in a backstage you stay
out but we'll put her in the back
yeah and we'll use our celebrity friends
and does she gets to meet Rogen and
everybody else
I'll just wait no no but that is a great
idea right bring her to stand up
yeah I'll line up but you gotta get
someone to swipe ID that's tough that's
the first fine kid Arnie let's get this
going
what happened wields Ward straight a
real love story he's gonna have a bunch
of bros I dunno one day with you second
yes I'm due dressed up like Juwanna Mann
be like I like oh I had these two
[ __ ] great dudes from Northern
Ireland they were so tall they were both
six foot five and and they were such
fighter and kid fans they'd come to see
us that night at the Comedy Store and
this one kid I guess was they were both
they both got too drunk they're just too
big and too drunk for fun and they were
they were trying to get me and their
girlfriends were too but smoke shows and
they were like we're so sorry I
they just love you so much they don't
know what they're anything I was like I
know and the poor guy was just trying to
hang around for him I'm from Ireland so
I could say that's cool so but yeah I
think that's a good call I actually
think you should introduce him to the
world of comedy and we will [ __ ] you
loosens you up we'll give you what's
called the McAlpine
you know what the McAlpine is over this
man Jimmy Burke who's just to each other
I'd be on a date with Amy and I'm
sharing out and we're just talking and
then we didn't we just met at the bar
whatever we did or whatever and I would
go I got to go call I got a call mr.
McAlpin really I'd go it's called giving
him the McAlpine so Brendan would go and
I would go good luck with that dude good
luck with that I hope he gets it man
what he's nice he's directing his first
movie with Clint Eastwood and it's just
really exciting we could go on stage and
then you know after our set night you
know the most would be possible that
[ __ ] right there sitting right there yes
do you know yes
that's allow you to do and then when it
when she's alone we go listen man that
was right the guy doesn't have a whole
lot going on but he's got [ __ ] a
connection to great below and I know
you're and that's why we hang out with
yeah that's right that is the play we
come with the package package that is
the play though huh yeah that's it
college show done I don't know I would
think that but that's it I mean
yeah bring it back to us come see us we
didn't think of it though I know it's an
easy one it's an easy one that's a lot
challenger bust it maybe just meet there
and then get drinks after something
around the comic sources shitload ado
there
mm-hmm that's the chinder you could
borrow the [ __ ] slingshot I wouldn't
want to drink and then driving that
slingshot we'd have to do burr it's a
fair point
are you working out I do some push-ups
now no I want you looking for a Joe you
in the gym looking for so hard to find
it's so hard cuz I was only 125 minutes
or throw a [ __ ] stick bro
throw a slit weird chin here like
literally a few blocks down
okay well box Martin's right up the
street that's how much that stuff cost I
will we will I will figure that out or
figure that if you commit to it I can
figure it out for you so get into
classes you'll get in great shape yeah
or from now it'll be depend there are
1000 girls hot girls in this class all
my friends who are single I go bro go to
box and burn 10 a.m. or the 5 6 7
o'clock classes
I mean yet straight up supermodels grand
[ __ ] it's crazy this is perfect yeah
because that that is he's making a good
point too I always think that when you
set a goal for yourself you know it
opens up other venues avenues it's like
I'm lonely okay so join a dance class
join a [ __ ] boxing class whatever it
is
oh and by the way by the way I think
boxing burns an amazing idea cuz you'll
get in crazy shape you know you know
there there are salsa classes all over
this [ __ ] town and if you don't think
there are single girls that want to
learn that if you show up and you know
how to dance and you go late on the
second date you go you want to go salsa
dancing and she goes I don't know
haunting them and you go I do I do
teach you clothes a lot of work I don't
seem like just go to box a miracle kill
two birds with one stone
I'm not having a good great workout and
then he has tons of chicks and they're
not yeah good price and then you go what
are you doing tonight
like I don't like I had two friends
should I go yeah I think they're
performing at The Comedy Store
Oh Harley Brian Brennan did you
ring-ring
that's it all right all right we'll do
it
hey does any alright to let for sure
let's get this shirt in let's start
swiping one more left little level for
God's sakes all right maybe we could
come up with a gym - sure - that's a
good call a fan made the dick diving
shirt that comes out I think this week
you're next that's hilarious
I love it absolutely love it I like when
the fan send it yeah I know the show
yeah it's really it's really good we
gotta have MJ do I find the kids social
media take over where you just post [ __ ]
for the days of people get familiar with
you okay
don't feel like you have to like go out
of your way and do like you I'm at Six
Flags now whoa I'm at the beach now whoa
you know just regular [ __ ] oh by the way
before I forget you need to get clear
when you travel do you have that where
I've TSA yes Hayes I laugh at that now I
Isis all clear I get clear I walk
through and I go like this they go
there's something hi how are you thank
you so much and I put my two fingers
they read my fingerprint dude and they
go I go right through no ID no no how
did you have to get it cost me a hundred
eighty bucks here I don't give a [ __ ]
the man I took Matt I travel know how do
you have to do it I just signed up it
took me all of five minutes here for
your port yeah but you wouldn't you
think they'd pull me online I was like I
was there I had time I had an hour to
kill the guy goes hey can I and I can I
talk to you and I go yeah and they
brought me over to take you five minutes
you give them you the first of all they
have your info beasts yet this took me
literally on a board
it took me they just did my fingerprints
it took me less than five minutes is it
worth sign up Simon does it work for
international yeah not really
yes yeah let's do you say didn't work
international yeah but but this I
believe works for international because
I've seen feeling I think
no that's Nexus yeah either way Nexus no
matter the amount of you and I travel
dude I walk right through and they just
they take your bag it's glorious it's
unfuckin real man no ID I don't even
need ID I just come does your wife have
teeth they know so bum but guess what my
kids travel with me so if I I have clear
they come with me for free my kids but
your wife does it
she stays in that line you wait all the
way how about my wife was cracking me up
I go like this today as I'm leaving as
I'm in Utah what she cracks me up she
goes crazy what happened I'd lost my
fault I go great news
I'm on the plane babe my [ __ ] is also
rock-hard do you mind if I gift it to
you it would gift you with it tonight
she goes by so weird a dick is like life
gets hard for no damn reason I was like
okay terrible joke you want to break and
go check it cuz it's a convertible right
let me grab it yeah you also want us to
nag it yeah alright we could just pause
alright I'm good some chocolate found my
phone got some chocolate at an empty
bladder huh chuckling I got a bladder my
phone looks like [ __ ] screen is cracked
case coming off because I'm waiting for
that goddamn iPhone 8 to come out
sisters come out September 12 yeah
you'll know [ __ ] about that no I was
worried about changing phones can I get
it
my phone is fine mm-hmm yeah you're
gonna have the six uh you have the one
but the thing is is uh have you ever
seen people who have a one yeah my
friends day one you're like holla I make
fun of them what's this outdated piece
of a what's it's rahi dinosaur
I know [ __ ] dinosaur heads fake my
buddy Jim Jimmy bursts got that like
that one or he's got the first one I'm
like I know certain people flip phones
but um yeah yeah I'm swaying for that
into the iPhone eight to come out my
phone looks like complete [ __ ] it's
almost embarrassing dude it is
embarrassing
what's with that phone look at the
summer glass fell off yeah it's
spider-man edition and then the case was
too thick so I've got one it's from
Disneyland yeah I don't know I got my my
class fixed it's 150 bucks but I'm gonna
get rid of full so why waste $100 yeah I
know it's cheap but I'm just as I get
older I don't like I don't know what
happened but I don't like that kind of
stuff I don't like any cracks or marks
I'm like it's bothering me I gotta fix
it you know me
and I'm like yeah I'm just gonna hold
out for this new iPhone yeah all you're
supposed to drop
did you drop let's go some kind of
offense with chinder Jenner
sounds good first one is do you know
this guy Brennan he's a belt or 180
fighter I know of him I don't personally
know
okay so surgery da Silva he was arrested
for robbing a New York City Bank a city
bank that's right on his block okay be
robbed
well first of all I mean what gave it
away that is just says the savvy no I
mean dude you're so easy to pick out in
a lineup number one number two I get
shirtless like what you see I don't know
I saw a giant that who says the savage
yeah and also not so that's offensive
American Indians well or it's offensive
that you're referring to them as savages
no that's what I'm saying
yeah the savages offensive well I don't
know why you're I'm not gonna get you
out of this one either I don't come on
all right so keep going to first of all
first of all let's just start with this
let's just start with this um guys if
your friend goes hey Brennan let's go
rob a bank I'm down to do as long as the
theme music is that I've always wanted
rob a bank to this must be some sort of
way out of here so to the please
that's Jimmy Hendrix right nice actually
no that's that's who Sanger but who
wrote it right II have no idea Bob Dylan
Oh Bob Dylan Oh Jimmy has a song he tell
that the theme music in life if grenades
grenades but wait who are you killing
what now you're throwing the money away
we just bought we just stole it stop hey
Noah ruff stop showering Russia weird
like working for sale Josh I don't want
to [ __ ] with the Russians police so we
get out anyways so it says uh let's see
law enforcement says the Brazilian put
on a style of this put on a ski mask
jumped over a glass counter into the
teller area
claiming to be carrying a gun threatened
to shoot people when you're screwed and
proceeded to make Ollie's in the same
block with roughly fifty
dollars he lives on the same blocks
acted alone was tracked down with police
after streamers were discovered oh so we
didn't even wear gloves this guy's a
genius
well here's this tells you cut but no
way that's me it's ever happened on
positive ever on the air god dammit
this is the same serger to silva who
tried to cheat his way past the New York
State Athletic Commission back in June
during belt or 180 official weigh-ins
check that out to weigh ins this is him
at the weigh-ins and look what he does
with his feet here he's 137 so check out
[Laughter]
so it said both feet please he's not
smart backyard like a real stupid beat
not smart dad stands still blue he says
dude he's a Spanish a brought the bank
round the bike guy he's on his block he
robbed a bank on his walk with a ski
mask without gloves and got his
fingerprints or her they were like um do
you know the average amount of money
people get away from robbing banks now
$3,000 I think less than three thousand
my god yeah everyone thinks you're
robbed bank and make like [ __ ] loads of
money it's typically around three
thousand they get away with and here and
I'm going 50 grand 50 grand well and
[ __ ] boy didn't have you know wait this
hell there's him trying to make way go
what else weird guy what a mess I know
what else get Jim okay um this is an
update on the other story remember the
MMA guy that passed away he got killed
during a home invasion robbery yes
they found the people who did it so
there's three teenagers one's a girl
she's what 16 years old and the other
two guys are 18 years old so what was
the motive behind it just a Rob so the
the guy let me get his name real quick
this kind of stuff worries me Aaron Raj
Aaron Rajan mm-hmm
he was talking to this girl I guess they
knew each other through a meeting at the
market so they're just acquaintances and
then one day these guys asked her to
call him to see if he's home and then
when they found out he was dinner they
robbed him so there might be some other
intentions involved too but
weird cuz why would you browse while
he's there an especially a professional
MMA fighter exactly it's a bad idea
so what's gonna happen these morons well
since they're from Boca Raton or Palm
Beach I guess it's gonna be it's
considered capital murder so if they get
convicted they're gonna get the death
sentence it's perfect yeah just morons
just doing dumb [ __ ] dum-dums 16 18 18
super yo all right
Burning Man a dude ran into with the
burning piece is that a picture of a
structure that's him running right right
before he ran in so he runs in
firefighter falls in the flames Brian
and did he die yeah he died but he
didn't die he didn't burn to death there
so he collapsed in there
firefighters grabbed him pulled him out
and then on the way to the hospital the
smoke and everything
yeah he's died about here pry it on so
much shrooms he thought that was like or
acid or some [ __ ] probably just got back
look fun he's post yeah they want me
they want me to go every year I'm just I
just I just can't I don't care about
communal kind of like ah they're all
culture they really cool this is a thing
like you listen there's no form of
currency accepted here oh cool how much
is it with our V and it's about 14 grand
yeah all right how much does it take
it's gonna be about $400 yeah I know
currency thing I was invited to one of
them and that guy was like we create our
own thing with buses and we have a sushi
chef and all I'm like dude that's you
know I'm not doing that and also it'll
cost me they said it'll cost us $10,000
each I was like okay Burning Man for the
elite I'm by the way I'm 52 I'm not it's
not for me it looks uncomfortable too
super hot in the desert I've got [ __ ] to
do man
and they ain't drive into the middle of
the desert to play [ __ ] Mad Max with
yeah it's like this idea of cosmic
alignment and being high or just being
loved it's it's fine it's fine it's it's
it's a romantics vision of how the world
should be and I'm just a little too old
but everyone's on drugs right that's a
little reason yeah [ __ ] and drug in
which I don't mind me neither but same
thing
need to go all that way to do that how
about I put a bonfire in my backyard
give you some drugs and me and Brian I
don't like having huge crowds around me
I worry about that I can't I don't like
it either yeah
so if I don't know I'm worried about
stampedes every shooter or just yeah I
don't know weird [ __ ] there's like
creepy Craigslist lads two guys will
post up do you want to go to Burning Man
and then they post up oh you can have
this RV this and this and this but you
have to be my girlfriend or whatever
companion I don't think really fine list
of them have you been man
no I've never been but I work for a guy
that creates like the our cars for it so
I do like admin for them yeah and these
cars are like $600,000 million-dollar
art cars that people hire him to build
for them and they start billing them
like tomorrow next year yeah they it
takes a long long process I've seen some
get belts you know from start to finish
it takes months it's stressful but uh
and just for that one trip right just
for one trip yeah like Elon Musk went I
guess last year like crazy people like
good wealthy people go but also like a
lot of a lot of interest it's a thing
for certain people I know some pretty
wealthy dudes who'd it's a thing for
them so most smartest people I know
though they're yeah again doesn't mean
it's for me yeah I'm just all dust
yeah just more the desert guy ran right
in that those flames though damn he
looked like he was just a little moral
well he was obviously not in his right
mind he looks cool there that happened
in 2014 to someone someone committed
suicide through the Burning Man yeah
yeah they ran through it they ran
through it yeah another thought they're
like mother of 70,000 people there's
gonna be one person to think she's the
mother of dragons babe 70,000 I'm sure
you got more than one yeah well that's
why they brought the I correct me if I'm
wrong they have a they have a line of
firefighters that are holding hands
right I mean they are surrounded with
secure and hub because they know some
healthy high shaking savage the name is
Aaron Joel Mitchell and he was obviously
he looked at Fleck just from the pic he
does he looks like a straight-up like he
looks like those last Mohicans right
there he looks pretty bad but with
sketches if you're gonna go that's a
pretty badass way to go God not really
well I'm trying to put a this is him
that's gotta be him let's see
let me see let me get pictures 41
handsome guys it's just crazy
donkey athletic looking guy crazy donkey
I wonder what happened maybe you just
say anything
scroll down chin maybe he just wanted to
die that way I don't know maybe he was
suicide because you don't run in there
thinking and be alright you see the
mother the Dragons which is fake
yes purchase fake he put the
firefighters at risk too though because
they don't go in and pull them out yeah
I'm looking him there oh wow the [ __ ]
did a swan dive into the Hall anything
he was so bad well I didn't scorpion
into the flame yeah thanks but I don't
know that's a bad way to die i him it
could be nothing worse than burning them
now it's gotta suck did say he was our
son
obviously I'm assuming sons crazy drug
he was a loving nice person Joe liked
hiking outdoors running and doctor fires
yeah I mean listen be right how can he
make joke to that listen he's the dance
that ran in there it was his choice now
if he was accidentally killed you can't
make jokes on it yeah I mean but when
yeah you have a ponytail you run the
fire and that's the way you want to go
yeah I I don't have that much sympathy
because he's 41 and he probably had
other problems and III don't have I only
have an is so much sympathy like I I
worry about children with cancer there
all kinds of things but a guy like that
you know I mean row yesterday I'm
watching this east 60s what the thoughts
kind of like ESPN's little mini docks
right and I'm watching it for the car
brothers David Carr and his and David
Carr and who's the quarterback for the
Raiders anyways two brothers Stabler no
well anyway so I'm watching for that
story but there you go before we get to
our feature here's another story of a
little boy I forget his name he was born
with a heart disease like a horrible hot
heart disease so they show him going
through all these freaking brain
surgeries operations yeah before he was
24 weeks olia to operations on his heart
first ever me Adam two weeks apart crazy
stuff so he starts doing better then he
gets real sick
and but the dad's filming everything is
I posted it for inspirational stuff like
please support son
well his sons like a year old and he's
obsessed with baseball in the Boston Red
Sox so the only thing I would make him
happy is the Red Sox so Shawn like
playing baseball like all this stuff
with the Red Sox
so the dads filming he goes I got good
news
he's like and they--but he's bound the
waiting list to get new heart because
heart's gonna fail if you didn't get
when he's gonna die so his dad's like I
got good news you're getting the heart
and the little boys like really when
English probably tonight
let me show they'll get crying he's
scared right it's horrible and I'm like
I'll [ __ ] this give me a great story
though okay
he gets the heart right gets the heart
the and then he's fine and then he goes
home the Boston Red Sox come to his
house Wow
look like to him come to his house and
play baseball with him follow through
how old is he
[ __ ] man 3 I just play baseball them so
the starting pitcher and the starting
catcher come he's playing baseball them
and like hey guess what Wow in four
weeks or so you know throw the first
pitch out first
and he's like oh my God he's so excited
I'm like dude this is cool
13 days later the kid dies yeah oh [ __ ]
I'm crying I'm watching I'm ball I'm
like what so risky hop so then yes and
then the the way it ends the mom threw
out the first pitch and that was hit
like I was like oh well they took you
down a road and then you're like you're
waiting for it to be a happy ending you
know I'm watching this it's gonna be
happy anything like oh and by the way at
13 days later see you later how crazy
I think they dropped you off a ledge
dude they tried they took you for a walk
they always have like they took you for
a walk it's wrapped you off the ledge
dude that's it was there was no like me
me and Joe were balling and I'm and I go
don't she's like crying cos there's a
rough stuff master SAS should I've seen
along with time and I go don't worry
he's me fine they wouldn't show this and
they're like 13 days after filming with
the Boston Red Sox he died at all hey
ESPN I'm tall
heartbreaking yeah it was insane I mean
gee whiz I know it's it's like it's a
crazy story but yeah well the David Carr
and his brother coming and running the
fires and children who died of
bad hearts next next Christmas a happy
story this guy's name is something Mac
match mattress Mac this is that so we
got an email because I was making fun of
Joel Osteen Osteen because he wouldn't
open his church doors yeah there's more
about a money thing for him so people
like here you know [ __ ] that guy check
out this guy and that's why this is not
okay go ahead oh this guy's he's like he
owns a huge chain of these really big
furniture stores and during the flooding
he's he invited anyone to come in and he
actually took out his own delivery
trucks to pick up people got and picked
up more than like more than 200 people
and he has at least 400 people at his
stores right now he lets him sleep on
all their furniture he doesn't care
about it he's like he was take care of
these no that's pretty badass
pretty good marketing - I'll go buy
everything from him he seems a good good
dude I'm sure he's a good great guy
Jordan I don't think about the market is
know so much I mean product isn't so
much but yeah it's a good folks on Joel
Osteen or the [ __ ] you know he opened
up his doors - no Joel Osteen after a no
no don't let this [ __ ] pass the only
reason he did is because he's got so
much heat from everyone yeah he's like
oh well yeah let's do it now no no yeah
he's a prick here's a donation fund now
- they don't know where the donations
are going - so now he's in backlash
about that because people are
questioning him where the money is going
now he's a snake this guy is not and
then people have already put out a
petition to give him a day like you know
the mattress Mac day or his name is
something Jim no Crockett Vail really
cool cool man over 170 thousand
signatures already so sexy whoo sex a
reporter right there
right how about JJ Watt raised 18
million now jeez Wow
eighteen point five wow wow that's
impressive as hell they showed another
use the NBA players
he's from Houston he was in a giant bike
truck just going around saving people
he's like yo hit me up on snapchat
Instagram if you're stuck I'm coming
around is you know that that according
to the for Kim they were saying that
base
quickly they were saying that hurricanes
you know they were blaming on global
warming and stuff but actually they ran
a really interesting article the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration
no but it could be it recently said it's
premature to conclude to human
activities and particularly greenhouse
gas emissions are causing hurricanes but
in this is happen this is this is well
also the main thing is this that the the
they were sucking around Houston is you
know it's because of fossil fuels it's
where fossil fuels are it's causing
global warming which is producing more
hurricanes in fact the link between
global warming and recent hurricanes an
extreme weather event is unsupportable
based on research and evidence and that
it's shown the data the Hurricanes
hitting the US have not increased in
frequency or in intensity since 1900 and
there is no notable trend up or down in
global tropical cyclone landfalls
since 1970 and floods have not increased
in frequency or intensity in the US
since 1950 and that is from the I have
it and I wrote it down I don't have it
but it's it's essentially the the United
Nations has the global climate panel
yeah you know which we where we get most
of our information from the scientists
that sort of said no chill out well
there's no arm again yeah so so so I
because I've been reading a lot in The
New York Times and stuff about like you
know our frequency of hurricanes and you
hear it on the media that this is global
warming but in fact if you actually look
at the same sources that a lot of those
people are drawing from those guys say
no don't turn oh I can't believe I'm
[ __ ] inter climate panel the panel on
oh I don't know about intergalactic
climate syndrome panel on climate change
or some [ __ ] like that
it's the Anna it's the climate are us
please do man I love how you have this
really or no I would this wasn't a
dropping knowledge I was just I read
this really interesting article to a
governmental Panel on Climate Change
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change 31 it is PCC the IPCC which is
the IP square really does set the
standard and it's what both sides of the
debate draw from they do exhaustive
research you know over years
and like a huge conglomerate scientists
and even they are not supporting the
idea that it's a little warming
well well they're not but whether or not
global warming is man-made is a
contentious subject I would imagine it
probably is I don't know I'm not a
climate scientist uh but most climate
scientists apparently are saying that
it's it's it's heard voice you might
yeah both points where it's pointing to
human activity or at least partially
okay that's all of it the debate becomes
are you going to be able to stop global
warming with more governmental
regulation that's where really the bait
hinges on but but what I think is really
insane I didn't know was that in fact
hurricanes flooding cyclones are not
according to this article are not in
higher frequency and that's according to
not only the IPCC but the other group
that I cited which I thought was
fascinating with the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration and those
are those are I guess really reputable
people so but you read about it it's
like oh we're all this [ __ ] change
and whether it's good it's good like
hurricane Harvey and Katrina and and war
was the one that hit in New York but
those are the ones that make headline
news cuz it's fun to scare people
breaking news yeah but if again if you
read New York Post you read some of
these other outlets like it's horrible
but it's also it's nothing other
ordinary on it right now
well there's frequent snow Armageddon
they've not a hurricanes if not
increased in frequency or intensity in
United States you know do that let's
hold each other next current event
release you're like yeah yeah that hurts
because I brings my little here a little
handy pick my my hands they run my heart
man yeah my handy Pandy hurts when you
do that
go ahead shout to the intergalactic
mmm-hmm
see sure I love I love Lil Wayne has
another had another seizure attack and
he canceled his Vegas concert gig from
all the scissored people are saying it's
because he's not stopping with that
scissor yeah he stays on it so it's
codeine sprite mix those together get
that purple star purple drank that
purple drank
he's insane which I really want to try
it he's a shot ape he's not he's well
hiney
his money's finished sure and same
person he's not this far bags under his
eyes no he just so much drugs name
damnit you got a little waiting for a
reason he's so tiny yes we saw Kendrick
Lamar like to you that I don't yes best
rapper in the world that little guy
Kenneth Regan he is what me by Nance I
said they're both skin okay but um she
just stays on that uh scissor huh mm-hmm
don't book couple I mean is it still a
popular thing I watched this documentary
on Vice land on scissor how it got
started and Houston all that I gotta be
honest I want to try it I wish I knew
someone get me some goodies in opioid
stay away from milk yeah I know what it
is I want sorry listen man no no I want
some purple scissors oh you are it
because I'm not try it with me
look I'm not getting you cooked on
opiates in the whole show go for [ __ ] I
don't have you iron you nodding off one
more [ __ ] time yeah Brendan's nodding
off old grill I look like polish a why
does he have a face tattoo well he's on
the [ __ ] you want to try a Sherwood
Sherwood we can try one hey try no
[ __ ] opioid Brian want me cook too on
it uncle anyone has hookups for a
scissor let me know no no supper oh I'll
try it for you get a vampire show up
that's how you get the vampires come out
of the woodwork because there plenty of
vampires want you to share in their
misery oh yeah yeah I don't want that
yeah my girl used to say to me she goes
I had to talk as to what she was a drug
addict said my cousin said yeah listen
come out of the bathroom
cuz I used to be a vampire too and it's
real sunny over here that's actually
plainly she goes so I I'm ready to hit
the sunlight now I was like alright man
please so little wings in the hospital
in the hospital
yeah just staying on the scissor this is
a lady who took some interesting
maternity pictures and beef she's a
beekeeper and a honeybee rescuer so
check it check these pictures out that's
here next to a bunch of bees she's
holding the Queen that's how you do it
and that's her baby in there - yeah but
when you hold the Queen all they do is
they just they surround you and they
want to protect the Queen they're not
gonna sting you but also don't
that should also be less creepy about
yeah well she said she's a she's a
beekeeper it's aa but let's call like it
is she's also batshit crazy pregnant
once we covered in B there's that these
are blessing her baby there are beasts
first of all the bees are white they're
warming her baby with their wings and
they're blessing her Instagram just a
hashtag queen bee haha yep yeah that's
gonna be that baby's gonna be sweet that
baby's gonna be super sticky yeah so
she's getting [ __ ] from people online oh
she says a lot of positive comments
is she gonna when she gonna have her
baby I'm [ __ ] funny man I'm killing it
today
killing it that baby's gonna sting when
he comes out hot sure it's gonna sting
ah
well those are terrible pictures but and
this is the last one I think car
sprayers burning fuel crowd to him
Hunter event well so during a burnout
this cars like you'll see this fuel and
fire yeah it's not if that does not feel
good
Oh Luke if you guys in his hand
okay ro looks like Donald Cerrone yes
hit with tires in the face with that
[ __ ] I'm not thinking out my thing to
get pressed up against the wall watch
cars go around and around yeah me
neither
I've noticed I've never been in NASCAR I
knew that interesting I didn't think my
brother's discovered a turn yeah ooh
first Sunday service since black
backlash
let me hear him let me clarify some
things this might be a little too long
but let's see I'm not gonna speak long
yeah somebody said Amen don't say that
now
but seriously you know there's been so
much misinformation about the church
this week I wanted to clarify some
things
saving his ass
well they love him so that's all I gotta
say this foot put black and whites black
and white when he put God knew that
Houston could handle the hurricane I
can't why quit being upset by something
you can handle this building flooded in
2001 when the Rockets were still playing
basketball here there was over 5 feet of
water in this lower ball knowing that
when we took possession we install large
flood gates around the building
last Sunday morning like Trevor was
saying when all the when it rained so
hard the water came within a foot or two
of breaching the new flood gates and
flooding the building again without
those flood gates we wouldn't be here
today so the water started receding late
Sunday maybe early Monday we felt like
it was safe to start taking people in on
Tuesday had we opened the building
earlier and someone been injured or
perhaps that it flooded and people lost
their lives
that would be a whole different story
and I don't mind taking the heat for
being precautious but I don't want to
take the heat for being foolish that's
alright that's fair that's fair
I'm gonna take mine his word I can't
people think that picture was from
before so scroll scroll down from me
chin so I to the article this issue I
have is so it says Joel claims his mega
church was always open to the public
despite videos an eyewitness saying
otherwise he blamed the internal
flooding for the delay that's the set of
security company might have been
responsible for turning people away
that's fair I'm gonna take him first
word I don't like being cynical
I love trust and by the way he did open
his doors so regardless he'll go late
but yeah he did a little late and if
that's true that does make sense and I
do believe him that it was flooded in
2001 and they put up flood gates and
that's a serious flood I mean that [ __ ]
was like so high so maybe he's right you
know
well you're more nice a minute I'm but I
don't trust him it for many of
well that's because you're not a man of
God and your office is going to hell so
you should go to church and clean
yourself up sir that's it I got a drop
in knowledge you bastards I thought was
interesting too and I want to see what
you guys think of this and I have a
point if you want it and I thought it
was kind of make references and you
can't remember I'm gonna boss
no I gotta do that I'm gonna do that man
I promise I'm gonna do that now mm-hmm
you have more chocolates down there
chocolates
those are good aren't they Jim can you
just hold on yeah and [ __ ] all right
let's see if I can find some of the Joel
Olsteen pictures lying and they're
coming up right now and no they're not
really it's just memes some memes to
reach up for the new you must let go of
the old what lies behind you is not
nearly as important as what lies in
front of you that's actually a nice
quote and religious at all MJ Oh super
skeptical private so I want to read this
ready super skeptic
uh let me get everybody's take on this
are we good Jim yeah all right so I
wanna get you guys take on this so I
don't know if you know that but children
of Congress members do not have to pay
back their college student loans
staffers if Congress family members are
also exempt from having to pay back
student that makes them members of
Congress can retire at full pay after
only one term Jesus hold on members of
Congress have exempted themselves from
many of the laws they have passed under
which ordinary citizens must live for
example they are exempt from any fear of
prosecution for sexual harassment and as
the latest example they have exempted
themselves from the health care reform
in all its aspects okay they don't have
to worry about health care okay cuz they
are taken care of now this is
interesting because if you look at the
28th amendment it reads as follows
Congress shall make no law that applies
to the citizens of the United States
that does not apply equally to the
Senators and or Representatives and
Congress shall make no law that apply
to the senators and our representatives
that does not apply equally to the
citizens of the United States so it is a
violation of the twentieth amendment I
just wonder do you think though that the
way you get good people in Congress is
by creating incentives since you're not
making that much money no no so they
just get I wonder what kind of perks I
know like if you're working as a public
servants should you get some perks well
shouldn't Esther's get perks I think so
what about teachers what about teachers
suits who have masters in the teaching
and middle school and high schools and
have all these student loans what about
them yeah are you telling me those
people are more important than the
teachers well I don't yeah I don't know
about the teachers you can make an
argument for that but I'm just sticking
to this for now do you think that do you
think that because you're a poke servant
we would get people who are more
qualified we didn't have to make that
much of a sacrifice I don't know I don't
know the answer I know the Constitution
says it's unconstitutional so let's go
reality yeah I was surprised by that too
well I'm saying my point is if you do
that with them who has more of an impact
on society them or the teachers well I
definitely teach there seem to be
underpaid in most cases not a whole
benefits yeah well they have benefits
not not like that yeah that's it well no
there's their benefit you know work but
not like that
grant they have summers off so quit
complaining but you know there's that
you do have so you're also working from
you know 8 to 3 still but you're
educating the young minds of America get
summers off though summers off 3 it's
kind of fun right nice kid when I think
about it you're also wrangling but how
we love teachers we love it we love we
love nurses but well no nurse is
different you talk about what cut hold
up you talk about the school nurse I'll
tell my nurse you fake nurse school
there's a nurse fake nurse big nurse why
aspirin let me see yeah you better go
home you're not sick [ __ ] I just said
I'm sick you don't know how I feel
you're not a doctor did you fake sick a
lot
no no you goody two-shoes huh no I just
you just you just were ready to practice
sports yeah I didn't fix it did you fix
a killer
only once when I in college when I was
oh I'm dizzy but still we'll call it
Jesus Christ Grubman but uh no I didn't
fake sick did you did you see that nurse
that got arrested in Utah because she
wouldn't draw the blood from an
unconscious patient freaked out on right
that cop screwed me he got in trouble I
don't know if you yeah what happened we
I think got fired oh because she didn't
give her consent the the personnel was
unconscious there they're supposed to
give a consent to get take blood from
them and the nurse was trying to protect
that person yes and the cop wanted to
get you know because you caused this
accident there's a huge accident so the
cop wanted to get proof that he was you
know maybe a DUI or something yeah and
then there just presented yeah yeah the
cop freaked out well he probably was
under a lot of pressure and furious at
this no the other cops like what are you
doing bro like the other cops were level
head like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you got a homeboy you got fired he was
just probably like had enough of it that
day though they're petitioning to fire
him to do my buddy my buddy hassled my
buddy I won't say his name but he's a
motorcycle cop and I still live next to
him down at Marina del Rey dude he had
to give he would give like 17 tickets a
day there was a quota he had to give
then a minute but you know you gotta
give a certain number katha gets but he
was always fair but he said dude he come
back and play his guitar and and he he
was like I might the amount of
negativity I take every day because I
gotta [ __ ] stop people from you know
like they stop and I give him a ticket
and the [ __ ] idea was I thought yeah I
can't believe you're doing this to me
and stuff like that you're [ __ ] you're
doing 30 miles over the speed limit but
the constant negativity that he would
deal with would just real job it just
yes the job he just said he wasn't cut
out for it he was more a musician he I'd
hear me strike just trying to get out
that's the gig was its I did a
ride-along in college and I would never
do again somebody's come in suicide the
person got shot and so you also deal
with [ __ ] like if you're a cop a lot
of no earlier yeah but you're also also
when you're a cop you're dealing with
tough cases a lot of times like there
are [ __ ] in the world and a lot of
times [ __ ] do
things and then you're dealing with
those [ __ ] there's just a lot of
negativity people crying people yelling
fighting I don't know man but no one's
like unless you're in trouble it's only
time someone's excited to see a cop
that's right if when you try what's the
first person he called better than that
he would when there's a gang get a
ticket [ __ ] your friend you're looking
for cops cuz you can tell like Gang Gang
Gang the gangs have done this fight this
weekend they're pretty sure why Edmonton
and that's not good
am I wrong on that chin I feel like I'm
almost positive hear this you got
schevchenko Nunez for sure no one here
is owned by my fans but Shevchenko Nunez
you got my team I want to see that fight
yeah but you didn't know what's
happening so you quietiy mouth oh you're
right except I'm sorry board great board
yeah mmm yes an idea I didn't look like
breaking news for you guys
I'm looking forward to that Valentina
Shevchenko five designers hasn't fun
awhile with Neil Magny what's your take
on that um there's a bunch of good
fights on there no and des gilbert
melendez back fighting Jeremy Stephens
at 45 55 so who doe Wilson is it's fun
Gilbert Melendez Jeremy Stephens the
banger the TV Pedro is really fun dos
Anjos Neil Magny yeah that's great I
mean about screeches Johnson ray Borg
that looks good though what's your call
it's part of the UFC's fault with
marketing it's just I really didn't do
the kind of you know dopamine release of
them Gregor stuff like done tough right
smushy and this talk to remember France
universe JDS was supposed to be on this
guard France and then genius got busted
mm-hmm what's your take can you just
break down what do you think about Nunez
eshenko
you want to serve the main eventers you
can pick a random fight uh well it's not
a ran that's a pretty mean ER I know but
you don't start with the domain of that
we mean Dimitri sound I don't know Ray
Bourque I've not seen sighs see remember
deep Demetrius Johnson was gonna fight
well everyone want to fight TJ but he if
he wins this fight he sets the record
right
Sylva coz could be honest with you when
I would I saw when I see Demetrius
Johnson fighting Ray Bourque you don't
care and the reason I don't care it's
cool I suspect of course exactly
yeah that's the [ __ ] like so I don't
even I know I know I don't care either
that's why I don't have to me I love to
meet you so he does that's why I have
Demetrius Johnson's my number one number
one would he fight it uh yeah I mean
it's just a different but then I guess
you have to have a number one that cuz
you got you know lopsy John Jones with
that stuff going he can't be in one
anymore
is there any new developments on Jones
Oh most recent thing he passed his blood
tests beheld the urine test
yeah I passed his blood heard you talk
about this on Rogan he's so he passed
the blood failed the urine but that
drugs only shows up in your urine so the
media's making a big deal passing the
blood has nothing to do okay the urines
the big one really and then I have chew
on the big round break down tomorrow
who's gonna break down all the ship for
us and jail was saying that that Toronto
ball that he tests positive for if you
take that your usual East acting with a
bunch other stuff really yeah okay so I
mean that's but you can't I mean it so I
guess you know my team us number one
John's out right down um so mainly Nunez
Shevchenko what you would who yet be I
think ultimately you might see the same
fight in a way I I got I gotta go with
Landon Nunez ultimately I mean Shankill
is awesome and a badass and I'm looking
forward to the fight but if I have to
put my money on it I'm sticking with a
man so please this be if you're gonna
say the same fires last time last time
if that would have been five rounds
Shevchenko would have won well cuz the
manliness gassed out and chef jr. turned
on later in the rounds but now cuz that
was a three-run fight rocket so they're
all rugged so now it's a five-round
fight so now a lot of people go wait a
second their first fight feels longer so
if chenko probably would pull it off
I don't think she's gonna pull it off I
think Amanda Nunez she's just on this
high I think she gets it done now she
gets it done in in that she stops her um
maybe she's gonna win though I think
she's just the champ it's her time I
think she gets it done but that but that
that cardio thing is a real issue
sometimes right so if she gassed it
three you you wonder
different pace though yeah and I believe
I feel like she's a better fighter than
when they fought back then I see I think
she's a dime piece Shevchenko
I like her am I am i wrong or I find it
very good for me I like the she's hot
I'm sorry you just want him to kick I
feel like I feel like I see Sachs if so
is a cave you seen that video Bryan and
rush me and kicked in the balls by
Shevchenko and then she [ __ ] oh right
yes you're just going how do you say you
like I'm all for spawn again she's from
Kyrgyzstan how do you say sorry in
Russian they don't sit that's not
doesn't exist in there you just take it
up how do you say - Oh Mitch means good
claw - oh gosh oh gosh Oh mom pancakes
my balls how do you say that Zee bullet
the bullet the bullet she's just wailing
away on your day on your old nuts ah
don't call him old dogs tight like my
face face my face dude she I think I'm
attracted or cuz she's such a like she's
so hard-working she's so [ __ ] mmm but
a man misses his hard-working - well my
name is she's either very gay
like she's gotta hurt bullets fantastic
she's gay her than I am for women like
she's you know she's a great loves lover
yes she does his her is her wife or
girlfriend in her corner yes and they
lived against me I'm glad that you bring
that up because we met nobody ever talks
about it it's it's very nice Auburn in
Vegas I'm sorry but the UFC is at the
forefront of not only women's rights but
gay rights am I wrong about that you are
wrong you are wrong the fighters are do
you a season that's what I'm you see
doesn't sell a fight UFC doesn't blast
outright but the human yes the [ __ ]
you'll see have you seen anything I know
like during Gay Pride Day why aren't
there you see gays fight get right like
you have a bunch of dude I hate to tell
you I'm sure there's some gay fighters
like fighters but I agree with you I
mean that's kind of that's kind of a big
deal it really likes your world
champions gay as flood they're in love
kiss each other and mr. cornermen and
they lived here come on how got my if
there's not billboards in West Hollywood
I have no idea why you don't do a
[ __ ] National Day Day in West
Hollywood with a man a newness and you
have seen their pot she's a pioneer in a
way it's a mullet I saw her in Vegas her
and I just like what's up champ earn the
yeah she's she's not overwhelmingly
feminine no she was she's Neela she's
not like super Dyke don't know
non-person okay
you know what you ops she's she's she's
not not my type yeah but however she is
a beautiful person I don't say like I
love her her face her body I'm a huge
fan like nothing but respect and I does
a booty to she does yeah but she's not
like she looks that way I thought she's
not okay
she's not she's like she has that you
wouldn't I know what you like you
basically like I like gosh shake without
this yeah guys without dicks she's not
like that okay I know what you like I
thought that me and Stevie same things
we like it we like a guy basically a
dude went with with with tits and no
dick we like that's really like it she's
not like that she's very family she's
like a beautiful-looking I love her so I
curd this symmetric of her face like her
skin what I would suggest very pretty
what I was suggesting was that because
she looks in camera she looks a little
bit more butch maybe that's why they
don't celebrate her I don't know that's
not fair I really doesn't though that's
a great story man come on she's got a
[ __ ] wife there cook coaching her and
she's a world champion give me a [ __ ]
break man that's a big deal now we got
Valentina Shevchenko she is she hooked
hipsters she single I think she's single
is she I think so his whole Brides way
to lighten the ass happen to be married
to but I'm gonna shoot you in the nuts
though in the snow by the way by the way
by the way she could drive that [ __ ]
into my thigh and I'd I take a knee
would not you get hard huh Oh femur and
my dick what about my boy Neil Magny
we're still San Jose well this is
fascinating to me because Neil is Neil
is Neil Neil is what chin is to all his
Asian friends so to horrify all designs
yeah Neil small here you you've trained
with them everybody
oh very well um never gets tired never
gets tired great cardio great cardio um
what's your call on that on that fight
cuz I I got Neil Magny do you know I
think he out strikes them even though
the Dodgers yep I think Jose Andres is
of great strike for everything else and
great wrestler but I think Neil's
weren't enough to stop the takedown and
I think I think he dos Anjos for
whatever reason you just can make you
why did you draw that out what
assumptions but since do you solder the
go and stitch kicked in he's not the
same fighter and I'll see I'm biased for
Neil Magny I think he gets it done it's
a tough fight for Neil though very very
tough anybody who fights dos Santos is
gonna be in for a better pack a lunch
then you're probably finished of the
night your most exciting one but the
last two on the main card are your fun
fights Melendez Jeremy Stephens yep in
the TV Pedro yeah I got a lettuce in
that fight even though he's been off for
a long time I I never bet against
Gilbert Melendez just what do you think
love Gil he's obviously part of the
Wolfpack yeah hate picking against them
are you I mean I would I would pick
against them right I like you know I
like Gil yeah outside power
it's tough fight forget he isn't look
great although Jeremy fights at 55 and
he's down to 45 right now we're not 45
he has yeah hasn't he always fought a 55
yeah but he's been in his last two okay
45 he's got a tough cut remembering
kills at 45 yeah that's
this is Gil's first fight at 45 minute
you'll see that's crazy
hmm lot to do wake up for both them like
this cards probably get 125,000 buys but
still it's a great it's a fun card it's
a fun one to watch yeah yes sir who
don't fight again god I was alone dude I
was facetiming with Tarek on the plane I
was facetiming and you know what you're
about to take off people are getting on
a planet it's kind of quiet
and I go I'm on a plane and he goes you
are I guess super life he goes show me
your dick and literally know everybody
around me turn and this dude just
started laughing standing he just
started [ __ ] die like a dude what the
[ __ ]
and then they always something goes I
want to see your dad cause I got a tip
for that card though yeah I don't sit
I'm innocent and I'll watch when I get
back but it'd be fun
um I'm really looking forward to we'll
talk about it later but triple G Canelo
no yes sometime yeah alright ma'am
listen if you guys are in Madison
Wisconsin September 21 22 23 I'll be at
comedy on state and then I'll be in
Philly at helium comedy club 28 29 30
come see me do stand-up at helium comedy
club in Philadelphia you filthy animals
Brendan where you gonna be
I'm in San Francisco next Thursday
September 14th at Cobbs comedy club it
might be sold out if not there's like
ten tickets left go to tea fat cake calm
right this second get to get ramen and
myself at Tommy's club next Thursday and
then I am at Long Beach Laugh Factory
September 22nd that is a Friday night so
Thursday this coming Thursday our next
Thursday
I'm at San Francisco and then 22nd
Friday night Long Beach Laugh Factory
you think it's right now t fact a dock
tom calm this is the finally kid